-Hi, everybody.
Welcome to another edition
of "Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
And it's very rainy
and cold here,
but I am braving the storm
while my wife
and dog and kids are safe
and cozy on the inside.
And I hope that you are
safe and cozy
on the inside of your home.
It's a great day
to stay at home.
We have a fun show tonight.
Blake Shelton is here,
country music legend.
Why was I doing that --
What was I proving by being --
nothing.
I was proving nothing
by being outside.
Anyway, I'm inside now,
and I hope you guys are inside
as well, safe.
Blake Shelton
is on the show tonight.
He's doing a song
with Gwen Stefani
to close our show called
"Nobody but You"
off of his album,
"Fully Loaded."
His charity tonight
is MusiCares.
They're doing something for
people in the music industry
affected by COVID-19.
It's a great charity.
Thank you for being here, Blake.
Also from "Saturday Night Live,"
you know him, you love him,
he's also in
"Trolls World Tour,"
Kenan Thompson is here tonight.
[ Clapping ]
Ah! We love Kenan,
and his charity is
nokidhungry.org.
And then later we'll be
playing a game,
an online game called
"Quiplash," which I love.
And the makers of that game,
Jackbox,
said that they will match
up to $25,000
in donations to
redcross.org.
So thank you guys for that,
and please donate
when the time comes
if you're watching on YouTube.
I'll be playing with
some fun people.
Alright, let's start the show
with a fun monologue.
Here we go.
♪♪
Welcome to "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
Well, guys, the weather here
has been crazy.
All day there's been
thunderstorms with wind gusts
of over 70 miles per hour.
I can tell my wife is getting
tired of me.
Today she told me
to take a selfie stick
and go film on the roof.
I almost got a chair squeak
out of that one.
-[ Chuckles ]
-That's right, the wind was
over 70 miles per hour.
The only fun part of the day
was gathering the family
in front of and open window
and re-enacting
Beyoncé at Coachella.
Let's get to some news.
Earlier today, Bernie Sanders
endorsed Joe Biden for President
in a joint live stream.
Yep, and like most streams
involving those two,
they stood there
for a few minutes
waiting for it to happen.
Well, guys, the CDC now says
that the coronavirus
can be spread
through your shoes.
Which means everyone's
about to become that
annoying dinner party
host who goes,
"Do you mind
taking off your shoes?
Thank you.
We just got our carpet cleaned.
And so, you know, just --
or you can leave
them on if you want.
We'll just -- we'll feed you
through the window."
Alright. I always had that
one neighbor growing up
that I had to like take
my shoes off and I go,
"Really? You think your house
is that nice?
Okay."
Okay.
Some TV news --
over the weekend
ESPN aired a seven-hour National
Spelling Bee marathon
and then a tournament of NBA
players playing horse.
Then afterwards, everyone turned
to the Weather Channel
just to feel something again.
A new "Bachelor" spin-off
called "Listen to Your Heart"
premiered tonight,
where 20 singles try
to connect romantically by
making music together.
So if you think it's bad when a
guy whips out an acoustic guitar
at a party, imagine
the entire party
is filled with that guy.
And finally, a 93-year-old
Pennsylvania woman went viral
after putting a sign
in her window that read,
"I need more beer."
[ Chuckles ] Yeah,
it was funny until
everyone realized it was
a 33-year-old woman
who's having
a rough quarantine.
It got even crazier when she
turned the sign around
and it said, "And shrooms."
You guys, that is our monologue
right there.
I wanted to check in on
my friend and our announcer,
Steve Higgins, who is at home
safely with his family.
Steve Higgins,
how you doing, bud?
-How's it going, Jimmy?
-It's so good to see you, man.
I miss you.
Oh, Zoom background.
-Fantastic, huh?
-Yeah. That's a good one.
I don't have that one.
-I upgraded to Pro.
It's fantastic.
-What is that one called?
-It's called
Tropical Paradise.
-I have like Space
and San Francisco.
That's all I have.
-Oh, dude, you got to
upgrade to Pro.
Check out this one,
this one is fantastic.
-What is this called?
-It's called
Man Looking at Waterfall.
Look at that.
-Mm.
-Majesty of the waterfall.
-Yeah, why not just show
the waterfall? I mean...
-You can kind of see it
in his eyes
if you look real close.
-Can you?
-Well, look, he's pointing
at it, see?
-No. What else do you got?
-Oh, this is my favorite one.
Check this one out.
-Is that a bag of dog food?
-Yeah, it's like I'm hanging out
in front of a big bag
of dog food.
Check it out, it's like
I'm almost there.
-Oh, yeah.
-I'm gonna grab that dog food.
-Is there any other ones?
-Oh, you're gonna love this one.
Boom.
-Ew, what's that?
-Mystery celebrity armpit.
Whose is it? We don't know.
-Mystery celebrity armpit?
-Yeah.
-Ew. [ Laughs ]
I wouldn't be able to guess
any celebrity armpit.
-No, that's why it's so great,
'cause it's a mystery.
-Hey, I should get going, dude.
This was --
-You know what?
-What?
I got to go, though.
-Mystery solved,
it's my armpit.
-[ Laughs ]
You got me, dude.
Very good.
That's great, buddy.
Nice to see you again.
Take care, okay?
-Wait, how are Franny
and Winnie?
-They're great.
They're so cute, I know --
Oh -- There's your kid,
your family's there too.
-Hi.
-They love you. They --
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah!
-So much fun.
[ Talking over each other ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter continues ]
-All right.
Well, all right, I'll see you --
you guys are nuts.
-Bye, Jimmy.
-We'll see ya, Jimmy.
I'm bleeding pretty bad.
-All right, guys.
We'll check in with you later.
-Oh, my God.
Who turned the lights out?